I've been tempted to quit comedy quit la
get up and leave like every second day
and I'm not exaggerating and just
thinking I'm driving home right now
to a bed which is just recent not even
that sometimes like a coffee maker and
like my guitar and like no real friends
I've got my brother thank God for that
if it wasn't for that I wouldn't be here
that's for sure but I think in the back
of my mind just going back to Vancouver
where are those people they give a
and and just living there and working a
normal job just so that I can see these
people and then it clicks in for me
again I go no you don't know you don't
you don't you're not going back to that
because the truth is those people don't
have time in their schedule and they
move on grow up have kids move to the
outer city like the rest of us anyways
my name is Josiah black and I'm a
comedian here in Los Angeles and I do
some freelance acting work as well I was
raised in a small town just north of
here of California called Canada it's
good Vancouver actually all right shy
stop the act is that I'll go all day I
will you do need to stop me like you
know I've gone through music acting
firefighting all this other stuff and I
just never felt so in my element other
than just telling jokes or you know
getting to be my quirky self and getting
away not only getting away with it but
being accepted and and praised for it
for those same things that got me fired
for more than half my jobs you know I am
that guy again I got moved constantly in
the classroom all the time growing up I
I was the wild one I was the oldest so
my younger brothers would always look up
to me and think okay don't do that
I like to see myself as like a mark
Whalberg of the four brothers you know
hey what are you doing
stay away from that don't touch that get
out of the way yeah now go you want to
go pick up some beer for you all right
all right I have been heckled I except I
never I never see heckling as being
heckled I see it as having a
conversation like oh okay you wanna you
want to step into the cage let's go
let's do this
one of us is gonna walk out alive like
it's fun like I've been told I'm I'm
like a warm really friendly presence on
stage and and since I'm so open like
that it engages people to want to speak
I remember I was heckled once so it
opened mic buy another comic I was
asking what I looked like you know cuz I
was doing this thing like I think I look
like you know Sean Penn or you know
DeNiro you know I do the thing and when
someone in the shadows way back just
shouted you have John Cusack's nose I
just stopped and I was like as I go
you have Eddie Murphy's shut the up
hey yeah I met Jay Leno just like a week
ago and that was a really cool moment
for me cuz I'm walking past the guy and
I'm like I it's a crime not to say
anything mr. Leno it goes yeah puts his
hand out shakes my hand young comic big
pleasure to meet you yes oh cool yeah
where you from where you from I go
Vancouver
actually it goes like 30 years ago I
like it you know a little club called
the comedy cave oh cool yeah keep that
for you it was like thanks my brother is
my my anchor out here we've got each
other's backs
like that's the best piece of advice to
anyone that I've got for trying to make
it in LA that's not even my advice you
need somebody you need someone and like
when you got each other you can watch
each other's backs you know just like
for is gum you know another thing we
should sleep on against each other's
backs that way we don't got a face in
the mud you know it you just need that
and you know you can share a room and
split the rent you can talk to somebody
about the day you had let alone them
that right there is worth it and it's
tough to find that in people out here
that don't want something from each
other you know he was 19 underage at the
bars and he would go in as my manager
Polly James and carry around a tripod in
a camera where this funky fedora hat and
that's what how it worked I got myself
in all these places and he would talk
people after shows and get me booked
I'll be up there on stage telling my
jokes and I'll put I'll have some new
material in there and I'll do my new
stuff that he hasn't heard and I can
hear his laugh as if it's the first time
he heard it out in the audience and I'll
know it's like there's Paul and it just
makes it feel like that much more of my
living room
you